depuis les profondeurs de l'espace mars
a toujours nourri l'imaginaire des
hommes
tout au long du xxème siècle livres
films et bandes dessinées de science
fiction ont été marqués par cette
fascination
les astronomes eux l'ont été tout autant
et comment s'en étonner avec ses déserts
de sable c'est calottes polaires blanche
comme la neige et les mystérieuses
marque à sa surface
marc se ressemblent davantage à la terre
que n'importe quel autre planète
depuis plus d'un siècle les
scientifiques débattent pour savoir s'il
ya ou non de la vie sur mars
récemment sur la base de nouvelles
découvertes
la polémique s'est intensifiée car des
indices semblent montrer qu autrefois il
ya très longtemps il y avait sur mars
un océan des données rapportées par des
sondes spatiales laissant entendre qu'un
énorme plan d'eau comparable à notre
océan arctique aurait existé près du
pôle nord de mars selon une des théories
en vigueur cet océan ce serait maintenu
quelques millions d'années avant de
disparaître mystérieusement
y at il vraiment eu un océan sur mars
et si oui comment at il disparu
et y at-il jamais eu de la vie dans cet
océan
la science n'est pas encore en mesure de
répondre à ces questions mais ce n'est
pas faute d'essayer
nous avons interrogé les meilleurs
spécialistes afin qu'ils nous expliquent
leur découverte et nous présente la
flotte de sonde qu'ils construisent pour
explorer mars
alors joignez vous à nous pour découvrir
cet étrange planète si proche et si
lointaine à la fois
les spécialistes s'accordent à dire que
du point de vue géologique mars est une
des planètes les plus intéressantes du
système solaire mais qu'en est il du
point de vue biologique
y at il de la vie sur mars où la vie at
elle pu s'y développer autrefois pour
s'éteindre lorsque la planète a gelé ou
qu'elle s'est asséchée toutes ces
questions fondamentales sont liées à un
seul facteur l'eau car son zoo il ne
peut y avoir de vie
au premier abord les choses semblent
claires mars est manifestement une
planète désertique dont la couleur est
celle du sable brun rougeâtre qui la
recouvre dans de bonnes conditions on
peut s'en rendre compte même depuis la
terre les gens qui observent mars avec
des télescopes on rapportait que des
nuages de poussière jaune soulevée par
le vent recouvre parfois la planète
entière et de plus près les sondes
spatiales nous ont montré dimanche champ
de dunes de sable auprès desquels le
sahara lui même semble minuscule
pourtant il apparaît tout aussi
clairement que mars n'est pas
complètement aride
c'est calotte glaciaire par exemple sont
composées au moins en partie d'auge les
biens qu'elles contiennent aussi du gaz
carbonique
il y à de la vapeur d'eau dans
l'atmosphère martienne et parfois
celles-ci se condensent pour former des
nuages mais les signes les plus
déterminants de la présence d'eau sur
mars sont d'ordre géologique
les images rapportées par les sondes
spatiales montre en effet dimanche
chenaux à certains endroits de la
surface plusieurs semblent avoir été
creusés par des blocs de roche ou des
débris charriés par des crues
gigantesque or il a fallu des volumes
d'eau bien supérieur au débit d'un
fleuve comme l'amazone pour créer de
telles sillon dans le sol de mars
mais le plus étrange à propos de ses
chenaux et qu'il n'y a aucune
explication manifeste de la provenance
de toute cette eau et qu'on ignore
également ce qu'il en est advenu par la
suite les chenaux semble très anciens
vieux au moins de 3 milliards d'années
les scientifiques pensent que mars avait
une atmosphère bien plus dense dans sa
jeunesse riche en gaz carbonique
cette atmosphère aurait provoqué un fort
effet de serre qui aurait permis de
réchauffer suffisamment la surface pour
que l'eau reste à l'état liquide
et si tenté que cette eau et était en
quantité abondante pour qu'elles forment
un océan
le problème c'est que mars est une
petite planète avec un diamètre
inférieur de moitié environ à celui de
la terre samassa atteint à peine le
dixième de celle de notre planète
les forces gravitationnelles martienne
ne sont donc pas assez puissante pour
retenir longtemps une atmosphère dense
au fil des âges géologiques
l'atmosphère se serait en grande partie
dispersées dans l'espace et l'effet de
serre auraient disparu avec elle tout
océan existants aurait forcément je les
ai avec le temps même la glace peut
s'évaporer se répandre dans l'espace et
se perdre
combien de temps mars est elle restée
assez chaude pour avoir un océan michael
car du bureau de recherche géologique
des états unis est un des principaux
experts qui travaillent sur cette
question en fait l'atmosphère est très
instable
s'il fait assez chaud pour qu'il y ait
de l'eau liquide
alors bien sûr le gaz carbonique de
l'atmosphère réagi avec la roche pour
former les carbonates et le gaz
carbonique kit l'atmosphère donc la
question n'est pas de savoir pourquoi
l'atmosphère est parti mais comment elle
a pu exister aussi longtemps car s'il
fait chaud
elle va s'effondrer ce qui pourrait
expliquer que l'atmosphère soit resté si
longtemps c'est la forte activité
volcanique
les carbonates se former dans le sol et
le gaz carbonique été rejetées dans
l'atmosphère à cause du fort taux de
localisme de cette période mars comporte
des volcans véritablement immense bien
plus grand que n'importe laquelle de nos
montagnes
pendant plus d'un milliard d'années il
serait entré périodiquement en éruption
peut-être même certains ne sont ils pas
encore tout à fait et un des volcans de
cette taille aurait certainement pu
maintenir l'atmosphère sur une longue
période ont ils permis à mars de rester
chaude et humide suffisamment longtemps
pour que la vie puisse se développer ne
le savons toujours pas il était habillé
en revanche que l'atmosphère s'est
dispersée au fil des halles aujourd'hui
la pression atmosphérique à la surface
de mars est à peu près la même que sur
terre à une altitude de 30 mille mètres
avec une couverture atmosphérique aussi
masse la température chute chaque nuit
jusqu'à 100 degrés en dessous de zéro
pas vraiment le genre de conditions dans
lesquelles on s'attendrait à trouver de
l'eau à l'état liquide
c'est pourquoi ces photos prises par la
sonde mars global surveyor ont été une
telle surprise on distingue ici ce qui
ressemble à des ravines formé par des
coulées d'eau ces structures sont bien
plus petit que les cheminots anciens
découverts à d'autres endroits de la
planète
mais surtout elle semble bien plus
récentes ça complique sérieusement les
choses parce que nous connaissons les
conditions actuelles sur mars
elles n'ont pas pu beaucoup changé
depuis disons un million d'années ans et
ravines semble vraiment très récente
ce serait surprenant qu'elle ait plus de
quelques centaines de millions d'années
à mon avis tout indique que ce sont des
structures assez jeune pour un géologue
l'idée que de l'eau ait pu couler à la
surface de mars aussi récemment qu'il y
à quelques millions d'années semble
totalement extravagante dans
l'environnement martien actuelle l'eau
ne peut exister que dans 2 état stable
la vapeur ou la glace
la gageure est désormais d'expliquer
comment de l'eau a pu couler même sur de
courtes distances dans des conditions de
température et de pression aussi parce
mais peut-être c'est ravine n'ont elles
pas été creusé par de l'eau peut-être
s'agissait-il de gaz carbonique liquide
c'est un élément très répandu sur mars
l'atmosphère se compose en grande partie
de gaz carbonique
tout comme les calottes glaciaires au
moins par endroits peut-être ce gaz
carbonique se trouve-t-il parfois piégée
juste sous la surface
quand la pression augmente il se
liquéfient et un bouchon de glace est
expulsé comme sur une bouteille de
champagne à flot de gaz carbonique
liquide jaillit temporairement et creuse
une ravine avant de s'évaporer
cependant cette théorie à une faille la
température conviendrait mais la
pression n'irai pas du tout pour du gaz
carbonique liquide
il faut trois atmosphères le triple de
la pression atmosphérique terrestre pour
que du gaz carbonique se liquéfie c'est
possible dans de la roche et peut-être
qu'on pourrait trouver du gaz carbonique
liquide avec une pression élevée dans de
la roche
mais pour reprendre votre analogie du
bouchon et de la bouteille en fait c'est
exploserait ça ne coulerait pas pour
former des ravines
une autre possibilité serait qu'il
s'agisse bien dom et n'ont pas d'eau
pure de l'eau salée une lourdement
chargés en sels minéraux pourrait
s'écouler à une température bien plus
basque de l'eau douce
cependant même lola plus à l'est
gèlerait dans les conditions de
température que l'on trouve sur mars la
meilleure hypothèse actuelle pour
expliquer que de l'eau puisse s'écouler
serait donc qu'il existe une sorte de
chauffage sous terrains l'équivalent
martien d'une source chaude
si la matière près de la surface à une
conductivité thermique faible alors elle
pourrait faire office de couverture
thermique qui réchauffe et la matière la
roche en dessous donc ça permettrait à
cette eau salée de se liquéfier et
ensuite de former les ravines mais
aucune de ces possibilités ne sont
vraiment séduisante vraiment plausible
c'est ravine reste une énigme
y at il des sources chaudes sur mars
de l'eau liquide coule t-elle encore
occasionnellement sur ce paysage glace
et trois milliards d'années après la
glaciation supposées de la planète et
s'il ya de l'humidité à la surface est
il possible que les microbes ne soit pas
très loin avant de pouvoir répondre à
ces questions nous devrons encore
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur mars
c'est la tâche à laquelle se sont
attelés de nombreux scientifiques et la
planète rouge se révèle être un
véritable pays des merveilles pour les
géologues
mars a toujours frappé notre imagination
une année sur deux lorsqu'elle se
rapproche de la terre la planète rouge
attire l'oeil comme un phare au milieu
du ciel nocturne
elle est alors la seule planète a
présenté des structures de surface qu'on
peut étudier depuis la terre
nos télescopes nous offre ainsi un
aperçu des plus attrayants de la surface
martienne surtout tous les 15 ans
lorsque mars passe à moins de 60
millions de kilomètres de la terre soit
la plus faible distance que nous
puissions espérer en est et 1877 l'une
de ses rares occasions permis aux
astronomes du monde entier de bénéficier
de meilleures conditions d'observation
possible de mars
mais bientôt une controverse se fit jour
on découvrit cet été-là des structures
sombre et linéaire qui sillonnait la
surface de la planète
les astronomes italien qui furent les
premiers à les remarques et les nos
mères canali ce mot signifiant chenal
fut hélas souvent à tort traduit par
canal qui évoque une structure
artificielle le 19e siècle était une
période faste pour ce type de projet le
canal de suez avaient été ouverts en
1869 et d'audacieux ingénieurs en
prévoyait un autre panama lorsqu'on
commence à parler de canots sur mars
d'aucuns furent donc tenter d'y voir un
signe de bâtisseur extraterrestre
d'autres pourtant resté sceptique à
l'idée qu'il puisse y avoir de l'eau sur
mars et encore moins des créatures
intelligent
issu de l'aristocratie de boston
percival howell n'était pas un sceptique
riche homme d'affaires et grand voyageur
ce passionné de sciences avait développé
un intérêt obsessionnelle pour la
planète rouge
ils pensaient être l'homme idéal pour
mettre un terme à la polémique des
canaux sur mars
dans ce but il fit construire en 1894 un
observatoire ultramoderne près de
flagstaff en arizona en mai l'étrange
aux structures érigées sur mars ils
étaient opérationnels
le télescope qu'elle abritait était un
excellent instrument d'observation
astronomique et percival lowell sont
servis pour étudier mars pendant 20 ans
observateur méticuleux il laissera
derrière lui des notes et des croquis
très complet ces dessins montrent
clairement ce qu'il décrivit comme des
canaux mais ceux-ci s'avérèrent des
illusions d'optique percival lowell
mérite notre admiration
avec courage il a tenté de distinguer
des structures qui étaient au seuil de
la vision humaine
or quand il est poussé à la limite
l'oeil tend à confondre des taches
sombres et brouillé avec des lignes il
n'existe pas vraiment ainsi les canaux
de percival lowell n'avait rien de réel
et ces martiens bâtisseurs n'était
qu'une chimère ironie de la science les
sondes spatiales d'aujourd'hui sont bien
en train de découvrir des preuves de la
présence d'eau sur mars en particulier
dans les régions polaires
c'est près du pôle sud de mars que se
trouve un paysage parmi les plus
étranges et les plus beaux du système
solaire le vent et des conditions
climatiques qui sculptent la glace
jusqu'à créer des formes qui ne
ressemble à rien de ce que l'on peut
trouver sur terre
non loin de là près du bord de la
calotte glaciaire un autre paysage
intrigue tout autant les géologues
c'est étrange step ou terrasses semblent
être des couches de glace contenant des
quantités variables de poussière ou de
cendres volcaniques formé siècle après
siècle
elle renferme peut être une chronologie
du climat martien une sorte d'équivalent
géologique des anneaux de croissance des
arbres peut être re celtel également des
indices quant aux mystères de l'océan
disparu les géologues lisent dans les
couches de sédiments comme dans un livre
ouvert
mais si les scientifiques ont hâte de
pouvoir déchiffrer ce livre ils vont
devoir attendre encore quelques années
une sonde spatiale devait atterrir à la
limite de la calotte glaciaire martienne
à la fin de l'année 1999
simplement baptisé mars pour la relance
d'heure par la nasa
l'engin devait analyser et photographier
ses mystérieux champs de glace mais à la
suite d'une panne tout aussi mystérieuse
la sonde a été perdu corps et biens
la précédente sonde martienne avait elle
aussi été perdus dans ce qui avait été
pour la nasa
la plus grande source de honte de son
existence l'enquète avait en effet
révélé qu'une entreprise sous traitante
avait malencontreusement faussé les
calculs suite à une confusion entre les
unités métriques et anglo saxon
personne ne s'en était rendu compte
jusqu'à ce que la sonde climatologie
orbiteur pénètrent dans l'atmosphère
martienne à une vitesse beaucoup trop
grande et à une altitude bien trop basse
au lieu de se placer en orbite l'engin a
brûlé comme un météore
ce sont donc deux sondes martiennes
d'affilée qui ont été perdus depuis
quelques années les responsables de la
nasa prenait une politique de missions
spatiales plus petites plus rapide moins
cher et des voix se sont élevées pour
demander si cela ne signifiait pas moins
cher moins bien conçu et moins bien
préparés l' agence spatiale est passé
par une période de remise en question
mais n'imaginait pas pour autant que les
chercheurs se soient découragés des gens
dont le métier consiste à explorer des
planètes sont en général optimiste de
nature choses concède l'espace dans
l'histoire de l'exploration il ya eu des
hauts et des bas je pense qu'il est
remarquable de constater que pour mars
nous avons eu des hauts et des bas mais
le résultat reste le même un intérêt
sans cesse croissant pour l'exploration
martienne la découverte d'éventuelles
traces de vie dans la météorite
martienne la sonde pathfinder ça c'était
une bonne nouvelle les mauvaises ce sont
les échecs mars pour la lande les maersk
line et orbiteur mais le résultat est le
même le budget a augmenté et l'intérêt
du public pour l'exploration martienne
s'est renforcée je pense que c'est parce
que les gens savent combien
l'exploration spatiale est difficile
c'est assez comparable à l'exploration
des océans du globe aux 16e et 17e
siècles
il ya beaucoup de naufrage que les
expéditions continuer je crois que c'est
pareil pour le système solaire à cause
de la sonde qu'elle a perdu la nasa a dû
adopter une approche beaucoup plus lente
de mars
l'objectif numéro 1 à court terme c'est
à dire au cours des 10 ou 15 ans à venir
et de rapporter des échantillons de
lieux sélectionnés sur la planète pour
leur intérêt scientifique et ce sera
difficile d'en arriver là
d'abord nous devons déterminer où se
trouvent les meilleurs endroits et c'est
déjà une décision difficile en soi
de fait mars regorge d'endroits de
grands intérêts scientifiques la planète
rouge est un véritable pays de cocagne
pour les géologues impossible de trouver
des volcans plus grand ou des gorges
plus longue et plus profonde où que ce
soit dans le système solaire
après des décennies d'efforts pour
analyser des données établir des cartes
nous avons appris à diviser mars en 3
grandes zones l'hémisphère sud et une
grande partie de l'hémisphère nord sont
fortement cratérisée et ressemble à
première vue à la lune tout au nord une
vaste zone est étrangement plate et
dépourvu de marque à l'exception de
quelques petits cratères et entre ces
deux zones
on trouve le dôme de tard 6
la région de tard 6 est une sorte
d'énorme renflement volcaniques sur la
surface de mars qui a été formé par les
émissions combiné de quatre volcans
gigantesque de plus de 15000 mètres de
haut sous le poids de toute cette lave
la croûte a atteint son point de rupture
et s'est fendu pour donner naissance à
un réseau complexe de canyon ceci mène à
l'immense valles marineris un gouffre de
5000 kilomètres de long assez profond
pour engloutir l'himalaya tout entier ou
presque
certains des chenaux creusé par les
crues commence près de l'extrémité est
de valles marineris mais la nature
exacte du lien entre ces deux structures
reste une énigme
en fait nous ignorons encore pourquoi il
y a des signes de crues sur une planète
aussi froides et sèches que mars et il y
encore peu de temps
nous ne savions toujours pas pourquoi
les deux hémisphères martien ont des
aspects si différents
la mission globale surveilleur a
révolutionné notre vision de mars
en plus des preuves de marque de
ruissellement d'eau la sonde nous a
donné les premiers relevés d'altitude
détaillé pour toute la planète grâce à
son altimètre laser désigné par
l'acronyme mollahs qui signifie en
anglais
altimètre laser orbitale de mars cet
instrument est capable de mesurer la
distance de la sonde au sol avec une
marge d'erreur inférieure à 1 cm c'est
grâce à lui que le principal objectif de
la mission a été remplie obtenir la
première carte en relief précise de mars
bien sûr nous connaissions déjà la
texture de la surface et des principaux
éléments du relief des cartes des
cratères des chenaux des volcans géant
avait été dressé 20 ans plus tôt
cependant nous ne savions pas encore
vraiment comment toutes ces structures
étaient liées les unes aux autres les
pentes graduelle qui donne de grandes
différences d'altitude sur de longues
distances n'apparaissait pas bien sûr
les photos prises par les sondes des
éléments déterminants avait donc échappé
aux scientifiques
c'est presque choquant qu'on n'ait pas
réussi à dresser une carte topographique
complète de mars qu'il ait fallu autant
de temps pour avoir mal car nous avons
envoyé plusieurs fois des orbiteurs
autour de mars la topographie c'est
fondamental voilà pour moi c'est
l'ensemble de données est le plus
impressionnant qu'on ait jamais eue pour
mars
grâce à ça on peut voir directement dans
quel sens vont les pentes les rouleaux
devrait couler on peut modéliser la
gravité et la topographie étudier la
densité de l'asub surface et mieux
comprendre la tecktonik les pressions du
sous sol c'est vraiment un ensemble de
données essentielle avant me là on
ignorait à quel point les plaines du bol
d'or sont si incroyablement plate on
n'avait pas une idée très claire de la
façon dont le bassin de crise et s'étend
jusqu'à regret plein d'issia au sud
par le passé c'était peut-être une voix
d'écoulement d'eau jusqu'à crise et les
plaines du nord
on ne pouvait pas voir la continuité
mais maintenant avec moi là on peut
l'une des découvertes permise par la
nouvelle carte concerne la grande zone
étrangement plate autour du pôle nord de
mars
une génération entière de géologues
s'était interrogé au sujet de ces
plaines qui ne présente aucune saillie
la carte d relief leur a fourni la pièce
manquante du puzzle
celle ci montre en effet que cette
région est la plus basse de tout
l'hémisphère
elle n'est pas seulement aux plates mais
en majeure partie parfaitement plane
c'est cette combinaison de
caractéristiques une surface lisse plane
et bas ce qui fait que la zone
ressemblent si étonnamment au fond d'un
ancien océans
certains chercheurs affirment même
pouvoir distinguer une limite à cette
zone qui serait un ancien littoral
dégradé par l'érosion
mais cette théorie ne fait pas
l'unanimité il y à un chercheur
californien nommé tim parker qui dans
les années 80 après avoir soigneusement
étudié les images de viking a conclu
qu'une grande partie de l'hémisphère
nord qui est très bas cette plaque avait
peut-être été recouvertes d'eau il a vu
ce qu'il pensait être des ligne de
rivage très floues le long des régions
montagneuses et pour lui ça ressemblait
aux côtes de l'utah et d'autres endroits
du sud ouest américain tim parker a donc
exprimé cette idée selon laquelle
l'hémisphère nord aurait autrefois
contenu une grande quantité d'eau bon
quand il a présenté sa la communauté
scientifique
l'épreuve était plutôt sommaire et c'est
seulement avec mars global surveyor
qu'on a pu déterminer les altitudes sur
mars de façon assez précise pour montrer
que parker avait peut-être raison et
qu'il a peut être raison car les ligne
de rivage qui l'avait dessinée sont
toutes à la même altitude
donc ça a porté à sa théorie la
crédibilité qui lui faisait défaut
maintenant la question est est ce que
ses côtés existe vraiment c'est un point
très discutée certains chercheurs ont
dit non elle n'existe pas ne voyons pas
la même chose que vous tim parker est à
mon avis la question est loin d'être
tranchée
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
certains experts récuse la théorie d'un
océan disparu se fonde sur la chimie
si dans un passé reculer mars avait une
atmosphère beaucoup plus dense et qu'un
énorme volume d'eau recouvraient
l'immense bassin au nord
alors certaines réactions chimiques
aurait dû se produire entre la roche
l'eau et l'atmosphère des minéraux nommé
carbonate aurait pu se former en grande
quantité pourtant bien que nos sondes
spatiales et effectuer des recherches
méticuleuses sur toute la surface de la
planète
elles n'ont trouvé aucune trace de
carbonate philippe kristensen est à la
pointe des recherches dans ce domaine
nous n'avons pas vu de minéraux argileux
qui sur terre se forme dans des
environnements humides moite et pluvieux
nous n'avons pas vu une classe de
minéraux nommé carbonate qui se forme
dans les océans
beaucoup de gens pensaient 6 mars était
humide avec des océans est un climat
humide qu'on trouverait les carbonates
et très certainement des minéraux
argileux
or cela n'a pas été le cas mais encore
une fois c'est peut-être parce que nous
voyons ce qui se trouve à la surface
aujourd'hui dix structures jeunes selon
des critères géologiques quelques
milliards d'années au plus donc ça ne
veut pas forcément dire que mars n'a pas
eu d argile des carbonates des hématite
et bien d'autres choses
au début de son histoire pour rechercher
des minéraux sur mars
philippe kristensen a principalement
utilisé un autre instrument embarqué par
la sonde global surveyor un spectromètre
démission thermique ou tess
l'équipe caisse avait pour objectif de
chercher deux minéraux en particulier
l'hématite et l'olivine le premier est
un indicateur de conditions humides et
le second de conditions sèches mais les
résultats n'ont pas permis de trancher
la question des océans disparu sur mars
car les appareils ont détecté la
présence des deux minéraux
nous avons fait des découvertes très
excitante en rapport avec l'eau nous
avons trouvé de l'hématite ou hématite
grise qui d'après notre expérience sur
terre se forme dans de l'eau dans des
océans des lacs ou des sources chaudes
dans tous les endroits où nous trouvons
ce minéral
il y à de l'eau beaucoup d'eau d'un
autre côté nous avons trouvé de
l'olivine qui est un minéral volcaniques
qui normalement se décompose dans l'eau
pour devenir un minéral archil simard
s'est échangé humide
nous ne devrions pas voir beaucoup de
livin pourtant il y en a en surface
d'un autre côté l'hématite nous indique
qu'à un moment donné dans des endroits
donnés mars a forcément dû être très
humide
nous pensons désormais commencer à
comprendre cette contradiction
l'hématide se trouve dans une zone très
réduite
c'est une région de la taille de
l'arizona et nous n'en avons trouvé qu'à
deux ou trois endroits sur la planète
donc elle est très rare et elle s'est
formée dans un endroit unique
c'est peut-être un endroit très anciens
peut-être que ça remonte au début de
l'histoire de mars un moment où dans des
endroits très localisés il y avait
beaucoup d'eau mais c'est vraiment
important pour la recherche de la vie et
pour savoir où chercher
tout au long de son histoire mars a subi
de profondes transformations aujourd'hui
pour mieux comprendre ces évolutions des
scientifiques visite et étudie des
régions parmi les plus reculés de notre
planète
et comme nous allons le constater il
commence à voir à la fois mars et la
terre sous un jour nouveau
notre difficulté à comprendre les
apparentes contradictions de mars
s'explique en partie par les idées
préconçues que nous avons tous après
tout l'homme n'a étudié qu'une seule
planète de prêts et cette expérience
pourrait s'avérer trompeuses
mais si les voyages permettent d'élargir
ses horizons
c'est doublement vrai des voyages
spatiaux ce qui est formidable sur mars
c'est qu'on a une surface de 4 milliards
d'années et il faut faire très attention
quand on étudie mars à ne pas se laisser
influencer par nos préjugés terriens il
y à peu d'endroits sur terre où on peut
trouver facilement des cailloux vieux de
4 milliards d'années
donc il faut garder en tête l'idée qu'il
est normal d'avoir des roches de 4
milliards d'années qui se sont formés
dans un climat humide et à côté des
roches de 2 milliards d'années qui n'ont
jamais vu deux c'est normal mais nous ne
sommes pas habitués à ça sur terre nous
sommes tellement braqués sur lock on
oublie parfois que marre ça peut être
une histoire très longue
les chercheurs qui tentent de comprendre
la géologie martienne ont étudié de
nombreux endroits sur terre qui
ressemble à certaines régions de mars
cette approche les amener dans des
contrées peu hospitalière on a par
exemple fait crapahuter des modèles de
robots d'exploration dans les paysages
arides du désert mojave en californie
des prototypes ont également été testés
dans la péninsule du kamtchatka à
l'extrémité orientale de la russie
ce site permettant aux géologues
d'étudier un terrain sculpté à la fois
par des volcans et des glaciers
l'islande est un autre terrain idéal où
les chercheurs ont pu analyser les
interactions entre volcanisme et glace
il n'est pas certain qu'il y ait jamais
eu de véritable glaciers sur mars mais
certaines structures martienne évoque
fortement le travail abrasif qui se
produit sous des couches de glace dans
les années 1970 les expériences
biologiques réalisés par les sondes
viking ont été reproduites dans une des
vallées sèches de l'antarctique dans ces
régions côtières des vents constants ont
érodé la glace et me le sol à nu ses
valets glacial et recouverte de gravier
sont probablement les régions terrestre
qui s'approche le plus des conditions
martienne or si les expériences des
sondes viking avait échoué à détecter
des organismes vivants sur mars
le résultat fut le même dans
l'antarctique
à l'autre bout de la planète il fait un
tout petit peu plus chaud dans un
endroit qui lui aussi évoque nettement
mars le cratère de automne il se situe
sur l'île de devon dans le grand nord
canadien
lorsqu'elle n'est pas remplie de
scientifiques devon et la plus grande
île inhabitée au monde
les chercheurs viennent ici pour le
cratère qui a été creusé par l'impact
d'une comète ou d'un petit astéroïde il
y environ 23 millions d'années depuis il
a été érodée par un glacier ou 2 est de
nouveau mise à jour le site offre un
excellent exemple de cratères d'impact
dans un environnement de permafrost
à tel point que la nasa a mené ici une
sorte de répétition générale d'une
mission martienne une petite base a été
construite et l'on a testé des
prototypes de scaphandres pressurisé
mais en explorant le site les chercheurs
ont fait une découverte fascinante
autour de juste en dessous du bord du
cratère il y avait des chenaux ou de
l'eau s'était écoulé de l'asub surface
or ces structures ressemble est
incroyablement aux étranges ravines ou
structures de ruissellement que l'on
venait de découvrir sur mars et qui
laissait les scientifiques si perplexes
les ravines sont vraiment un mystère
elle ressemble énormément à des
structures de ruissellement d'eau et on
trouve exactement la même chose dans
l'arctique canadien
en fait on pourrait prendre certaines
photos de l'île de déveine pour des
images de mars se ressemblent énormément
mais le problème sur mars évidemment
c'est qu'il fait si incroyablement froid
à ces latitudes élevées il fait moins 60
- 70 degrés donc il est très difficile
d'avoir de l'eau liquide
l'équipe du cratère de houghton n'a
jamais fait l'expérience d'un tel froid
les chercheurs ont quitté l'île avant
l'hiver mais même s'il était resté les
températures dans l'arctique canadien ne
descendent jamais si bas que sur mars
de plus lille de devon offre un luxe
dont des astronautes ne pourrait certes
pas profiter sur mars
une quantité illimitée d'air respirable
la lune pourrait constituer un meilleur
terrain d'essai pour préparer une
mission martienne
nous ne sommes pas retourner sur la lune
depuis 30 ans mais les leçons apprises
par les astronautes des missions apollo
s'avèreront utiles elles aussi pour
explorer mars des scaphandres
pressurisée seront nécessaires à la
surface martienne et la faible gravité
rendra peut-être les déplacements
difficiles
la gravité sur mars est deux fois plus
forte que sur la lune mais trois fois
plus faible que sur terre de telles
conditions sont impossibles à simuler et
s'il arrive un jour sur mars les
astronautes devront peut-être
réapprendre à marcher nos recherches sur
la lune et les autres planètes du
système solaire ont montré qu'il existe
très peu d'endroits où la vie serait
susceptible d'exister
mars pourrait être une de ces exceptions
mais si la vie a pu un jour se
développer sur mars ils sont nés peut
être fallu de peu il n'est en effet ni
couche d'ozone protectrice sur mars
ni champ magnétique et on y observe une
pénurie chronique d'oxygène en outre la
vie n'est possible que dans une certaine
fourchette de température et bien que
nous ne soyons pas certain de la limite
inférieure mars ne doit pas en être loin
mars est la clef de beaucoup de choses
elle est tellement similaires à la terre
il n'y a presque rien qu'on ne puisse
pas trouver sur mars il ya des dunes sur
mars des glaciers des tourbillons de
poussière de la neige de la glace et des
calottes polaires
elle ressemble beaucoup à la terre
pourtant la seule chose qui pourrait
manquer c'est la vie donc on a deux
planètes très semblables
toutes les deux ont de l'eau l on tue
des lacs des sources chaudes et d'autres
formes d'activités il y a de la vie sur
l'une il y en a t'il sur l'autre c'est
la question fondamentale et les deux
réponses possibles sont passionnants oui
il y a de la vie c'est une découverte
incroyable
non il n'y en a pas c'est une découverte
très troublante pourquoi est ce ainsi
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qu'est ce qui
rend la terre si spécial nous pourrons
apprendre beaucoup de choses sur la
terre en étudiant mars
mars même si elle ne nous apprend rien
d'autre nous aura au moins permis
d'apprécier à sa juste valeur notre
propre planète car nous avons eu
énormément de chance dans la loterie
cosmique la terre à toutes les options
couche d'ozone champ magnétique grand
océan liquide et même les luxueuses
plaques tectoniques auto recyclables
sans oublier une grosse lune décoratives
en cadeau
lorsque les planètes ont été distribués
il semble que nous ayons eu le modèle
grand luxe
la nasa veut retourner sur mars
après avoir analysé les échecs des
dernières missions
l'agencé américaine a réaffirmé sa
volonté d'explorer la planète rouge
les occasions d'envoyer des sondes
spatiales vers mars se présente environ
tous les 26 mois lorsque les trajectoire
orbitale des deux planètes les amène au
plus proches l'une de l'autre au cours
des prochaines années
la nasa prévoit d'envoyer ne sonde à
chacune de ses fenêtre de lancement
les chercheurs prépare notamment une
mission qui collectera des échantillons
à la surface martienne pour les
rapporter sur terre
l'étape numéro un c'est de décider où on
va atterrir pour ramasser des rochers
ensuite il faut envoyer des petits
robots comme cette journée heure pour
caractériser cette zone où d'autres
zones de la planète et se faire une idée
de ce que sont ces roches
en fait nous n'avons que des
informations sommaires sur leur
composition
on peut à peine dire si elles sont
volcanique ou pas si elles sont
cristalline on ignore encore s'il y a
des roches sédimentaires sur mars
c'est seulement après ces préliminaires
qui occuperont les trois ou quatre
prochaines missions que la nasa sera en
position de rapporter des échantillons à
plusieurs endroits sur mars on trouve
les roches stratifié que l'on pense être
des dépôts sédimentaires dû à de l'eau
ce travail actuel pour une grande partie
de ces structures
mais nous devrions prendre le temps de
réfléchir aux différentes façons dont
des roches stratifié peuvent se former
l'eau est une possibilité des dépôts de
sédiments au fond d'un lac représente un
mécanisme raisonnable pour expliquer la
formation de telles roche
mais ce n'est pas la seule possibilité
les roches stratifié peuvent se former à
partir de dépôts de poussières c'est à
dire des matériaux en suspension dans
l'atmosphère qui sous l'effet du vent se
déposent couche après couche le même
genre de roche stratifié peuvent aussi
se former autour de volcans à la suite
de coulées de lave ou d'événements
volcano clastiques c'est à dire des
explosions volcaniques qui génère des
cendres lesquels vont là aussi ceux
déposés sous forme de roches stratifié
donc on a trois mécanismes l'eau le vent
les volcans qui tous peuvent produire
des dépôts d'apparence similaire mais
malheureusement nous n'avons pas les
données nécessaires pour choisir entre
les trois
pour obtenir ces données les chercheurs
utiliseront notamment un instrument
nommé tennis il s'agit du successeur du
spectromètre tu es ce qui a permis de
découvrir de l'olivine et de l'hématite
sur mars dans les années 90 mais et
temis est bien plus précis depuis son
orbite autour de mars il détectera des
minéraux à la surface même s'ils ne sont
présents que dans de petits
affleurements isolé l'appareil pourra
également prendre des photos de la
surface de nuit ce qui pourrait nous
réserver des surprises
ce qui est fantastique avec les
infrarouges
c'est qu'on obtient non seulement des
informations sur la composition chaque
minérale ayant une signature infrarouge
unique mais aussi sur la température
en fait on mesure les émissions
d'énergie plus un objet est chaud plus
il aimait de l'énergie donc on peut
connaître sa température
alors si on regarde mars la nuit le
soleil se raccrocher et son action pour
réchauffer la surface aura disparu hélas
si nous voyons des endroits anormalement
chaud ce sera une indication de chaleur
interne est l'une des possibilités les
plus séduisantes pour la chaleur interne
encore une fois ce sont les sources
chaudes
s'il ya une activité volcanique ou de
long près de la surface voire de l'eau
chaude ça réchauffera la surface et on
pourra le voir si on cherche de la vie
sur mars
aujourd'hui une source chaude est le
meilleur endroit qu'on puisse explorer
si tout se passe bien les deux
prochaines missions martiennes
apporteront des résultats stupéfiants et
elles ne font qu annoncé une série de
projets plus ambitieux encore car les
chercheurs veulent récolter des
échantillons de la planète rouge pour
les rapporter sur terre dans leur
laboratoire martien est très riche et
très prometteur en termes de nouvelles
découvertes
je suis sûr que nous aurons des
découvertes à chaque mission et c'est la
séquence que nous avons prévu doit mener
à un retour d'échantillons qui serait le
premier d'une série
la communauté scientifique est unanime
pour dire qu'on ne peut pas se contenter
d'un unique retour d'échantillons
il faut que nous avions une série de
retour d'échantillons avant de pouvoir
vraiment comprendre mars de ce point de
vue et pour en arriver là
nous avons toute une série de missions
prévues est l'étape ultime bien sûr
serait d'envoyer là-bas des hommes déjà
des instruments embarqués dans les
sondes spatiales mesure les niveaux de
radiation dans l'orbité martienne pour
déterminer la faisabilité d'une mission
habitée
si les procédures de quarantaine le
permettent tôt ou tard des explorateurs
humains quitteront lé orbite martienne
pour se poser au milieu de ces étranges
paysage
ils prendront les photos collecteront
des échantillons chercheront des
fossiles et peut-être résoudront il
enfin le mystère de l'océan disparu s'il
n'y a pas eu d'océan
si cette zone ne représente pas le fond
d'un très ancien océans sur mars
alors il faut se demander pourquoi
est-ce aussi plat les géologues ont des
réponses
ça peut être des sédiments déposés par
le vent qui auraient formé une couche
ça peut être des coulées de lave qui
aurait recouvert des régions immenses
ces deux idées ne sont pas non plus à
exclure
à mon avis la première question pour les
scientifiques c'est qu'y a t'il sous ses
plaies j'ai grandi à l'époque des
missions apollo où on envoyait des
hommes sur la lune la nuit j'observais
la lune avec un télescope
j'ai commencé à regarder mars et à lire
des choses sur mars la lune est un
endroit plutôt statique sur mars je
voyais les calottes glaciaires évoluent
et pour un gamin qui regarde dans un
télescope ça changeait c'était un
endroit dynamique donc tout de suite on
commence à imaginer si j'étais sur mars
maintenant qu'est-ce qui se passerait
quand j'avais 12 ans la nasa a envoyé
une sonde qui a survolé mars
il est 7h30 du matin je m'apprête à
aller à l'école et la télé annonce dans
20 minutes des images en direct de mars
c'était incroyable alors j'ai dit à ma
mère est ce que je peut sécher les cours
et visionnaires comme elle et elle me
dit bien sûr donc je suis resté à la
maison j'ai regardé les premières images
de mars en direct
il y avait des paysages extraordinaires
et ses petites photos avec beaucoup de
grain mais le seul fait de me dire c'est
retransmis de mars aujourd'hui au moment
où je regarde
c'était vraiment captivant et j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler sur d'autres
missions vikings global surveyor odyssey
et cette émotion là de me dire si je
regarde cet écran dans trente secondes
je recevrai l'image d'une autre planète
ça me captive et quand j'avais 12 ans et
ça n'a pas changé
mars a captivé bien des hommes au fil
des ans notre compréhension de la
planète rouge a évolué mais la
fascination resto la même aujourd'hui
une armada de sonde spatiale s'apprête à
scruter mars de près pour répertorier
ces minéraux élire sa signature
thermique
nous prendrons le pouls de la planète
rouge si elle en a un et nous ferons
également une biopsie si possible ce
vieux monde gelée qui a dévoré temps de
nos engins spatiaux a à peine commencé à
nous révéler les étranges secret de sa
longue histoire
il est très possible que le meilleur
soit encore à venir